hey Gary my name is Richard I reach my
daughter 17 she's going to a meeting
tonight with my wife yes to discuss with
her school her university options what
she wants to do she's incredibly
courageous marketing mind communications
mind I'm taping you right now and I'd
like you to talk to her like she was
your 17 year old daughter in terms of
how she should consider her university
career how she should maximize that
experience to prepare her for the world
that you see she may be entering into it
um so her name is Kiara Kiara I have no
idea what's about to happen but it's
about to get interesting Kiara here's
what I would say Kiara I would tell you
that there is not a school on earth not
a university or college that exists that
isn't even remotely equipped to educate
you properly on communications and
marketing in the world we live in today
so I have no interest here to get your
mom and dad mad at me but I would tell
you that here would be my four year
strategy I would go to university
especially as she going here in Canada
she's she's talking about NYU she's
talking about San Fran is she collecting
debt or you guys paying for it I think
she's just enamored by big brands but is
she gonna pay for college yeah well
we're paying for it so she's not
collecting debt no Wells yep done it by
apologize we're paying for it and yes
she's gonna have to collect debt along
the way
all right Kyra you're gonna have to have
a weird conversation with your mom and
dad because the first thing I'm
passionate about is for you to not have
any debt because if you're gonna go to a
business that is going to sell you a
[ __ ] product that you are then going to
pay compounded interest in that you
can't even declare bankruptcy to get out
of that's called extortion [ __ ] up
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
but but Kira if that number is not that
high and you can get some other things
that drives down that cost the second
move would be to take your last
four-year ocation of your life hook up a
whole bunch have or not a you know
depending on your own radar here that
maybe one dude seven that's on you don't
let them judge she's a nice good
Christian girl I'm sure she is
and if you want to learn about marketing
and communications spend a lot of time
online and consume relevant
20:17 content from people that are
actually doing it not professors that
are so not practical and so romantic of
how it used to be that I've traveled the
best universities in the world and have
literally thrown up all over myself
while I've been prepped to talk
listening to the horseshit that those
professors are shoving down these kids
throats
you're welcome brother Bob you